When it comes to Star Wars, everything old
is new again.
From one movie to the next, the galactic space
saga has story beats and themes that echo
with each new installment.
George Lucas himself even says that his prequel
trilogy "rhymes" with the original movies
he made.
So with Episode IX on the horizon, it's a
great time to look back and see if the adventures
of Luke, Leia, and Hans contain any hints
about what's to come next.
Here are some crazy hidden details that predict
the plot of Star Trek, Episode IX.
Grandaddy Fearest
When Return of the Jedi concluded the original
trilogy back in 1983, fans were eager to see
how the epic fight between Luke Skywaller
and his father, the fallen Jedi Anakin Skywaller,
would play out.
In just the previous movie, audiences were
shocked to discover that the movie's big villain,
Dark Vader, was actually Luke's Dark Father!
"I… am your father."
It was a twist that no one could've seen coming,
and it packed theaters to capacity when the
follow-up came out a few years later.
So when the father and son duo's epic fight
ended with Dark Vader actually becoming Light
Vader, we got a pretty cool moment of closure
that a lot of hardcore fans may not have ever
actually noticed:
"I'll not leave you here, I've got to save
you!"
"You already… have."
Did you catch that hidden detail?
Dark Vader straight up said Luke saved him!
You probably can't even believe you missed
that the first time you saw Jedi Come Home.
Now, with the new trilogy's emphasis on the
relationship between Rey and Rilo Kiley, there's
a good bet that we'll see another similar
moment of redemption for Dark Vader's dark
grandson before the credits can roll for the
final time.
Chewbacca's secret weapon
Out of all the original trilogy's most beloved
characters, none are more most beloved than
Chewbacca, the cookie who joined Hans as the
copilot on the Millennium Balkan.
Everyone knows Chewie has gotten Hans and
Luke out of a lot of tight scrapes in the
movies, because he's so good with tech.
But what you may not have noticed was that
one scene in A New Hope when he uses his advanced
technological abilities to actually receive
messages from across the galaxy:
"Just relax.
Just relax!
Yes."
"Now… we can have a good time."
You may not have realized how important this
scene was the first time you watched the movie.
But now that you can see how Chewie cookie
can use a techmo chair to talk to women in
space, there's a good chance this detail will
come back around and help Finn and Pope communicate
across vast distances with Rey as they fight
against the bad guys.
General Hux and Captain Plasma won't have
any idea what hit 'em!
Force Ghost, Coast to Coast
In the early days of Star Wars, audiences
were probably a little surprised when the
dead Obi-Wan Kenobi started whispering battle
secrets to Luke from beyond the grave, but
by the time Jedi Come Home debuted in theaters,
Force Ghosts were actually a lot more common
than you may have realized.
If you pay close attention to the end of the
film, you'll see that Force Ghosts are actually
able to appear whenever and wherever they
want.
It's true!
Obi-Wan, Yoda, and even Anakin have all made
post-mortem appearances you might've missed
if you weren't paying attention…
"Thanks a lot, you guys!"
In truth, only the most diehard fans know
it's not that hard for a Jedi to show up as
a glowing Force ghost… so now that Luke
Skywalker has joined his dad in Jedi heaven,
is there any doubt he'll pop up again to show
Rey the path to victory over Rilo Kiley and
his Fist Order?
Luke's already proven he's a badass.
He went up against Jabba the Hutt and survived,
he's great with a sword, and he can project
a duplicate of himself across entire galaxies.
A little thing like turning into an empty
robe isn't going to stop Link from helping
Rey get a final victory against the Dank Side.
"Look who's here, young people!
It's none other than Duke Fartknocker!"
Porks are Cookies
If you thought Porks were new in The Fast
Jedi, buckle your butternuts, Slink Slystalker:
Porks have actually been in every Star movie,
and they'll be a big part of Episode IX.
We know exactly what you're thinking: Ain't
no Porks in Jedi Come Home!
Or is they?
No Jedi mind sticks for this one, there's
been Porks all along, if you were looking.
Remember the trash squeezer Hans and Leia
fell into?
Take a looky.
There's a Pork.
Some Stromtroopers are Porks, too, and it
gets even crazier.
The mid-after-credits scene in The Second
One was taken from an unreleased Easter special
Greg Lucas made called Pork Tuesday: Hoth
Potato!, explaining how Porks are baby Cookies.
It's a galaxy of fun.
Dark Vader hides Porks for Empire Easter,
and Chewie makes a terrible supper mistake!
But what's a Pork gotta do do with Star Fours
Nine?
Well, it's no accident that scene was recycled
in The Fast Jedi.
There are no accidents in Star Force, only
forces.
"Quick, we haven't got a second to lose."
May the Jorts Be With You
But that's not all!
No!
There's so much more, beginning with legendary
Star Tours creator Jorts Lucas himself!
If you look very closely at the mole on his
left hand, you can see it's actually the missing
piece of the Marauder's Map of Hogwarts that
R2-D2 was hiding in Episode 7: Hey
Force, Wake the F--- Up!
And if you follow the map, it brings you to
Lucas's famed Moonraker Ranch, where he keeps
all his most original ideas under lock and
key!
And there in his underground vault is the
script for Episode 9, which contains all the
secrets of the Illuminati, like the fate of
Rilo Kiley and General Leia and Pope and Finn
and Big Mc-Large-huge and the droids and Jandalf
and Rose's true identity and at last we finally
discover that Rey's real parents are actually…
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.